over the last decade and a half we've
moved from describing cancer as it
appears under the microscope to a
molecular diagnosis of cancer that's
based on the changes in the genome
next-generation sequencing technologies
have allowed us to discover those
genetic abnormalities at a dizzying rate
generating terabytes and petabytes of
data that overwhelm the ability of most
cancer researchers to wrangle and
understand there's just too much data
it's in too many places and it's too
diverse with the genomic data Commons
you'll be much easier to get the data
and to analyze it at the scale they need
one of the really important parts of the
genomic data Commons is having the
ability but every time a data submission
happens to analyze it in exactly the
same way and harmonize those data with
all the other data that's been submitted
to the genomic data Commons there's no
other resource out there like it we can
compare our data for our patients to
data that came in through the Cancer
Genome Atlas studies from many other
studies we will be able to do a lot of
analysis without having to download a
lot of data we'll be able to analyze it
online the GDC is an essential tool if
we're going to understand the data we
collect get the information we need out
of it to improve how we treat cancer the
GDC provides an exciting new opportunity
for cancer researchers they will be able
to upload their own data to the GDC and
therefore use all the bioinformatics
tools that are present in GDC to
understand their own data but also to
see how it relates to all of the other
data over time this will also increase
the size and the number of cases that
are present in the GDC giving us greater
statistical power we can start to do a
much better job tailoring specific
therapies and specific treatments for
patients based on the experience we see
with
patience you can't overestimate the
power of this tool to help us understand
how to manage our patience
what drugs to give them and as this
grows what are they going to respond to
these drugs or not this is going to help
us all the genomic information is really
life or death to our patients it makes
such a big difference
you